[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einen schönen guten
abend 15 minuten nachrichten haben wir
jetzt für sie natürlich auch mit sport
mit katja stresow guten amt
großbritanniens premier könnte heute
sein amt verlieren unsere themen
nach party gate die stunde der wahrheit
großbritanniens premier johnson muss
sich noch heute abend einem
misstrauensvotum stellen
besucher an der front präsident seelands
gereist in die umkämpfte ostukraine und
warnt vor einem russischen durchbruch
und feiertage in vollen zügen so war das
pfingstwochenende mit dem man euro
tickets
der britische kombos johnson hat ja
schon einige skandale überstanden aber
jetzt wird es für ihn tatsächlich
politisch eng in diesen stunden muss er
sich einem misstrauensvotum seiner
eigenen konservativen partei den tories
stellen der grund johnson war während
der korona lockt bei uns auf partys
dabei waren die zu der zeit ja verboten
stimmt heute eine mehrheit der tory
abgeordneten gegen johnson ist das ein
amt loslassen herr lang
die überreste des langen feier
wochenendes zum siebzigsten
thronjubiläum der queen sind noch nicht
ganz weg geräumt da steht in londons
innenstadt bereits die nächste aufregung
ins haus das seit langem herbei
geredeten von vielen lang ersehnte
misstrauensvotum gegen boris johnson
bilder wie diese ein zu locker und
zeiten in der downing street feiern der
premier hatten dazu geführt dass die
dafür nötigen 15 prozent aller
konservativen abgeordneten die
abstimmung erzwangen
man kann nicht für die aufstellung von
lockdown regeln verantwortlich sein und
dann zulassen dass diese regel unter
eigener oberaufsicht unverhohlen
gebrochen werden
trotz party gate und anderer skandale
hat johnson allerdings noch die
unterstützung zahlreicher parlamentarier
und kabinettsmitglieder
er wird weiter für das land liefern und
auch die nächsten parlamentswahlen
gewinnen
doch diese szene
berufe bei der ankunft johnsons und
seiner frau beim dankgottesdienst für
die königin vergangenen freitag war für
so manchen womöglich das signal dass mit
johnson eben doch keine wahlen mehr zu
gewinnen sind von dem glanz eines seine
königin und sich selbst fahrenden landes
ist auf den regierungschef nichts
abgefallen stattdessen hat das jubiläums
wochenende noch einmal den kontrast
verdeutlicht zwischen einer
pflichtbewussten und verlässlichen
königin und dem aktuellen
premierminister
diana zimmermann in london hinter dem
parlament findet jetzt gerade das
misstrauensvotum gegen johnson stadt wie
eng ist es denn politisch wie
es ist sehr eng allerdings wird schon
davon ausgegangen dass er das heute
abend gerade so noch überlebt es ist so
dass er selber tatsächlich überhaupt
nicht gewillt ist auch zugeben er kämpft
er hat heute seinen abgeordneten noch
einmal in erinnerung gerufen dass er
ihnen den dreck sieg beschert hat und
die wahlen noch 2009 10 für sie gewonnen
hat er hat außerdem steuersenkungen in
aussicht gestellten mitten in einer sich
anbahnenden rezession und es ist wohl
auch so dass einigen abgeordneten
persönlich posten und ehrungen
versprochen wurden wenn sie denn für den
premier stimmen wenn er heute man bleibt
liegt es auch daran dass es keinen
natürlichen nachfolger für ihn gibt und
wenn das so ist dann besagt die regel
dass es ein jahr lang ein weiteres
misstrauensvotum gegen ihn geben darf
allerdings keiner seiner vorgänger hat
ein solches votum lange überlebt und
wenn die konservativen erst das gefühl
bekommen dass sie mit ihm wirklich keine
gefahr mehr gewinnen können dann werden
sie sicher mittel und wege finden ihn
loszuwerden einschätzung von diana
zimmermann dankeschön
zum ukraine krieg da der russische
außenminister lawrow für jetzt direkt
die auswirkungen der sanktionen zu
spüren bekommen er musste seine reise
nach serbien absagen weil mehrere
europäische länder den luftraum für sein
flugzeug sperrten lawrow bezeichnete das
als feindliche haltung und kritisierte
die eu und die nato würden versuchen
serbien in der freien bei seiner partner
zu behindern über die aktuelle lage im
ukrainischen kriegsgebiet berichtete
nein aus ein präsident im krieg spricht
denen mut zu die diese krieg zu
flüchtlingen macht bomben und raketen
haben sie vertrieben aus mario pohl ihre
zuflucht jetzt sa borussia
ein bunker in der kleinstadt solider
nächster halt der präsidentin reise ins
kampfgebiet kurze lagebesprechung dann
anerkennung für die soldaten
helden des krieges dank euch gibt es
unseren boden und unseren staat jetzt
und auch in zukunft
so nah der frontlinie war der präsident
bisher nie auf sabrina und solider folgt
noch lässig die zwillingsstadt des
umkämpften severo donetsk dort haben die
russischen angreifer nach kurzer
gegenoffensive der ukraine wieder boden
zurück erobert
wir hatten beinahe schon die halbe stadt
befreit aber die lage hat sich für uns
nun wieder verschlechtert
auch präsident selensky gibt zu in
severo donetzk ist russland überlegen
und er warnt sollte moskau im don was
durchstoßen werde es schwer für die
ukraine das am wochenende beschlossene
eisenbahn werk in kiew hier widersprach
heute die barden gesellschaft der
russischen behauptung dort seien panzer
zerstört worden tatsächlich würden in
der fabrik waggons für den transport von
getreide hergestellt
ob und wie die ukraine wieder getreide
exportieren kann darüber wollen moskau
kiew ankara verhandeln seit kriegsbeginn
ging ja kaum was gesperrte hießen nicht
sichere seewege die russische blockade
im schwarzen meer die folgen weltweit
spürbar rund 22 bis 25 millionen tonnen
getreide hängen laut ukraine ist
präsident im land fest jetzt gibt es die
idee die vater ukrainischen exporte von
odessa aus durch das von den russen
weitgehend beherrscht das schwarze meer
bis zum bosporus zu sichern mit der
marine großbritanniens und der türkei
und johannes hano ist für uns in der
ukraine johannes wie wahrscheinlich ist
es denn dass es da zu einer lösung kommt
also im moment sind das alles nur
gedankenspiele es ist eher
unwahrscheinlich dass es eine schnelle
lösung geben wird der russische
außenminister lawrow wird nach ankara
reisen aber der ukrainische präsident
hat eben gerade vor ein paar minuten
sagt wir sind dazu gar nicht eingeladen
worden so diesen gesprächen weder ich
noch mein außenminister dass er also
alles relativ witzlos die russische
nachrichtenagenturen vermelden es gäbe
eine lösung die russen würden seien
bereit die ukrainische frachtschiffe
durch das schwarze meer zu begleiten
auch das ist reine illusion der
ukrainische präsident sagt der einzige
schutz den man wirklich braucht es
werden anti schiffs raketen und
internationalen begleitschutz
durchstarten denen man vertraut und
russland würden das bestimmt nicht
vertrauen sein haus minister hat er noch
beigepflichtet hat gesagt wir werden
ganz bestimmt durch die korridore von
minen räumen um sie dann sozusagen für
russische landungsoperation freizumachen
also nach einer schnellen lösung sieht
das nicht aus und es wurde auch gesagt
das problem werde von tag zu tag größer
er sei nicht mehr 22 bis 25 millionen
tonnen sondern in fünf wochen sein dass
schon fast 75 millionen tonnen denn dann
steht die neue ernte an
wirtschaftsminister herr beck ist in den
nahen osten gereist ganz oben auf seiner
agenda die themen energie und
klimaschutz
zum auftakt sprach in jerusalem mit
israels premierminister benjamin
langfristig zusammenarbeit bei
erneuerbaren energien und der produktion
von wasserstoff nach israel besucht habe
ich noch die palästinensergebiete und
jordanien
wie bekommen wir die klimakrise in den
griff darum geht seit heute in bonn im
rahmen der un wird der nächste
weltklimagipfel im november vorbereitet
schon jetzt halten viele
wissenschaftlerinnen das 15 grad ziel
für nicht mehr erreichbar
aktuell liegt die weltweit 1,2 grad
erwärmung mindestens drei grad erwärmung
gelten als wahrscheinlich und genau
deshalb richtet sich der blick immer
mehr auf die anpassung an die klimakrise
dabei geht es vor allem auch um
finanzielle unterstützung ärmerer länder
die sind oft am härtesten betroffen
normen odenthal mit einem beispiel aus
nepal
wenn die fliegenden ameisen zu flattern
beginnen ist das ein klares anzeichen
sagen die bauern und tatsächlich die
wolken hängen tief zwischen den bergen
aber es hört auf zu regnen endlich für
bauer indra eine gute nachricht
eigentlich war alles zu trocken der
heftige regen kam völlig unerwartet wir
brauchten regen aber zuviel es eben auch
nicht gut das erschwert unsere arbeit
unser leben
es ist verrückt indra hat alles oft
dürre eingestellt er hat speicher
errichtet um den sonst so spärlichen
regen zu sammeln er baut pflanzen an die
es gern trocken haben und jetzt das
vielleicht ist das was die bauern in
dieser region nepals gerade erleben so
eine art lehrstück sie versuchen sich
auf die dürre einzustellen und dann
müssen sie mit heftigen und langen regen
zurecht kommen klimawandel ist
unberechenbar und er trifft nepal hart
steigende temperaturen lassen die
gletscher schmelzen die extreme sind
längst alltag von trockenheit und dürre
bis zu überflutungen erdrutschen
aufhalten kann nepal die entwicklung
kaum der start schickt wissenschaftler
in die dörfer sie beraten die bauern
sensibilisieren für das problem machen
vorschläge
das traditionelle wissen der bauern dass
sie von ihren vorfahren kennen verliert
an gültigkeit weil sich mit dem wetter
auch die wachstumsphasen der pflanzen
verschieben sie müssen sich unbedingt
anpassen
sie sammeln wasser setzen auf neue
pflanzen verschieben anbau zyklen
bekämpfen schädlinge biologisch es sind
kleine schritte sachte methoden den
versuch ist es wert
die zahl der fälle von affen pocken in
ländern in denen das virus sonst nicht
vorkommt steigt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation zählt 780
fälle die allermeisten davon in europa
57 sind es in deutschland weiterhin
seien hauptsächlich männer betroffen die
sex mit männern hatten sagt die whu und
schätzt dass die dunkelziffer weltweit
deutlich höher liegt und ganz aktuell
hat die britische gesundheitsbehörde
heute 77 weitere fälle gemeldet
über das lange pfingstwochenende sind
viele regionalzüge schon immer
proppevoll vor allem in urlaubsregionen
diesmal aber kam noch das 9 euro ticket
dazu ein echter härtetest also für die
rabattaktion die bahn und vor allem für
kundinnen und kunden an ihr capellos
berichtet
pfingsten mit neun euro ticket am
rostocker hauptbahnhof in der s-bahn
richtung strand kommt nicht jeder mit
besonders voll die züge die reisende aus
berlin an die ostsee bringen
der es angst mehr geschafft hat ist
erleichtert
hauptbahnhof eingestiegen sind wollen
wir reingeschoben war für neun euro
reißt da kann nichts erwarten das ist
halt die züge sind voll aber
bewusst beste draus machen
nutzer in sozialen medien posten am
wochenende wie es an verkehrsknoten etwa
in hamburg zuging andere zeigen brechend
voll abteile oder dass die bundespolizei
wegen überfüllung räumen musste zu
wenige sonderzüge so die kritik des
fahrgastverbands
dazu braucht man die züge dazu braucht
man das personal und für längere züge
braucht mehr längere bahnsteige und all
das haben wir nicht die kapazitäten zu
reisezielen wie warnemünde reichen schon
seit jahren nicht dank neun euro ticket
ist es im badeort noch voller als sonst
vor allem die pandemie gebeutelte
gastronomie profitiert von den spontan
besuchern bereich des tagestourismus
glaube ich merkt man das schon aber im
hotelmarkt glaube ich ist das jetzt
nicht so relevant dass neun euro ticket
weil wir natürlich schon seit langer
zeit ausgebucht sind das eine der
wichtigsten reisezeiträume
wir fahren für wenig geld der zuspruch
dafür ist enorm so die erste bilanz zum
billig ticket
zum zug und lob bei garmisch
partenkirchen nach einem zeitungsbericht
der welt hatte die deutsche bahn an
diesem streckenabschnitt in knapp drei
wochen sanierungsarbeiten geplant bei
denen dann auch schienen erneuert werden
sollten ob es einen zusammenhang mit dem
unglück gibt wollte die bahn laut
bericht nicht bestätigen heute wurde der
letzte umgestürzte waggon für den
abtransport zerlegt bei dem unglück
wurden fünf menschen getötet mehr als 40
verletzt in diesen minuten findet ein
ökumenischer gottesdienst statt um der
opfer zu gedenken hatten die kirchen zu
einem gemeinsamen gebet aufgerufen
so und jetzt kommen wir zum sport die
deutsche fußball-nationalmannschaft hat
ja wirklich ein ordentliches programm
gerade ja in der nations league den vier
spiele binnen zehn tagen an morgen abend
partie nummer 2 gegen england in der
wohl ausverkauften münchner arena und es
gibt gute nachrichten für den
bundestrainer alle 26 spieler waren beim
abschlusstraining dabei
schulhaus am vormittag in herzogenaurach
allerdings ist marco reus nach seinem
infekt noch keine option für das spiel
morgen nach dem schwachen auftritt in
italien steht für den bundestrainer eins
fest klar müssen wir die dinge besser
machen ohne frage aber dazu sind wir da
und freuen uns auf das spiel natürlich
auf den klassiker gegen ändern es wird
sicher ein paar veränderungen geben nico
schlotterbeck david raum bei harvard
oder ilkay gündogan allesamt kandidaten
für die startelf der stratege von
manchester city hat das fliegt ganz
besonders angetan ich schätze ihn sehr
als spieler aber auch noch mehr als
mensch weiß einfach einfach und toller
toller mensch ist das klingt doch sehr
nach einem einsatz von anfang an
ja das zweite spiel dieser gruppenphase
gegen england können sie morgen abend
live aus münchen im zdf sehen los geht's
um 20 uhr 15 viele namen wurden
gehandelt jetzt scheint schalke 04
fündig geworden zu sein bei der suche
nach einem trainer nach zdf
informationen wird der ehemalige
bielefeld coach frank kramer den job
beim bundesliga wiederaufsteiger
übernehmen er soll morgen offiziell
vorgestellt werden in gut fünf monaten
beginnt in katar die fußball
weltmeisterschaft und gestern abend hat
sich wales als letztes europäisches team
für das turnier qualifiziert durch ein 1
0 im playoff finale gegen die ukraine
der entscheidende treffer fiel in der 34
minute wales superstar gareth bale mit
dem freistoß den der ukraine andrej
jarmolenko
unglücklich ins eigene tor köpfte
der ex dortmunder am boden zerstört
wales damit seit 64 jahren wieder bei
der endrunde dabei
hat man es auch gewinnt ja ein geschenk
hat ja schauen wir kurz wie das wetter
wird
morgen im westen schauer im süden
gewitter teils auch länger anhaltender
regen sonst wechselnd bewölkt und
überwiegend trocken 15 grad an der
nordsee bis 25 grad in berlin
christian sievers hat um 21.45 das
heute-journal für sie und hier begrüßt
sie am morgen mit drei serien auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]